well uh good afternoon everyone uh so
our next session is on training the
toxic python environment on your laptop
so we have Mr dasas putina with us uh so
Mr dasas has been a individual
contributor to python over a large
number of years now and we are glad to
have him at data 2023 so without further
Ado I welcome Mr dasas and user
hey folks so I'm between you and happy
hour so um I'll try and make this
reasonably interesting hopefully um who
here
has been using python for a year or two
okay anyone more than 5
years anyone not want to admit how many
years they've been using it okay has
have any of you had to install a python
package have you had to work out how to
install a python package okay so my name
is daras uh I uh I work at quanite we're
a open- source company uh we do we have
a lot of folks uh who are core
contributors of numpy site by pandas py
Lear all that kind of stuff and we do
Consulting and um I'm going to date
myself I was originally I'm from you
know my background is aerospace
engineering and I was originally writing
things in Fortran and Pearl and a and
said and a lot of ma lab and then in
2008 I found Pyon and I looked this
up I've been trying to install stuff in
pth for a long time this is a this is
the Sci-Fi user mailing list from
October 2008 and I'm like hey I heard
this thing that called pythons setup.py
install is that how you install numpy
and okay so I've been here for a while
and even though python is painful to
install now
when I was a kid you had to walk up walk
uphill in the snow both ways and compile
everything to so it's a lot
better but it still
isn't this comic from XKCD came out 5
years ago when it first came out I
didn't know whether to cry or laugh
unfortunately I still don't know whether
to cry or laugh should I use cond should
I use pip should I use poetry should I
wait no do I show do I double tock
installer like no what's going on
um who has written python code that runs
in their machine handed over their
colleague friend or someone else and
they're like nothing
works yay not yay but yay I mean this
this is this has been a frustration for
me for many years and now since I
actually work at a company that does
open source I been able to do something
about it um what's the problem here the
problem here is is we are benefactors of
a massive community of libraries when I
started python in 2008 um numai was the
big thing now numai is way down here
there's a lot of people I've met who
don't even know numpy exists they work
in pandas or polers or stats models or
biopython or you know um astropy or
something way at the top and I don't
even even know that numpy is a thing
this is a huge ecosystem
and it's built collaboratively around
the world by thousands of
people to do cool stuff and backwards
compatibility it's not even a
afterthought it's not even a thought
like I remember back in the day who know
who remers Sun Microsystems they had a
thing you could take a binary from
Solaris one and plop it into Solaris 12
it would just work you go from handa's
1.5 to
1.53 maybe your stuff two no
everything's gone you know nothing
works backwards compatibility is not a
thing with Pip and there's reason for
that the the cool new stuff that's
coming out is cool and it is amazing
but it's an
issue this is an image I pulled from the
internet of a simple Library I don't
remember which one um but a simple
library that is used and all the
different packages and dependencies it
depends on this is
complex the environments we use for
doing our
work are difficult to create they're
difficult to maintain and they're
extremely difficult to
sh who who uses requirements.
txts who uses environments. yo who uses
both
okay neither of them are perfect they
all have problems you know this is not a
cond versus pit versus poetry thing
all the the the state of the Pyon
ecosystem for packaging is problematic
there are social reasons for this there
are historical reasons for this there
are really strong technical reasons for
this Python's a glue language that calls
other languages so we don't only have
our own packaging problems we have all
the packaging problems of rust and C++
and everything else we depend on um I
don't have it in the slide deck but if
you look at the abstract I link to a
blog post which talks about kind of the
deep technical problems and kind of
what's the way forward on some of these
ecosystem wide
problems python is the bane of
Enterprise it people they hate us um we
want flexibility we want the latest
version of pandas we want oh polers came
in I want to try polers
uh I want the next version of oh you
know the late I don't know if you know
py torch compile is now a thing you can
take your nonp code and you can do it at
compile and you can run your nonp code
on GPU that is a feature that came out
in the latest version of py
torch we want that flexibility we want
to be able to do
that the flip side is reprodu
reproducibility becomes a problem
because as we're moving really fast we
install stuff how this is typically what
I've seen most people do like I need to
use Python going to download it I need
to use these packages I'm going to
install them oh I want to use the next
version of this package cond upgrade um
CP install minus minus upgrade this
package oh there's a new thing coming
out oh there's a new thing called poers
P install
poers you agglomerate or aggregate this
environment over time that is now this
holy thing that if you push it slightly
it will fall over and you cannot reach
create it
because you did installations at various
points in time and the state of the
internet and available packages was
different at those times if I even if I
take even if I have requirements.txt
even if I have a environment. yo you
know cond if I ran that 6 months ago and
I ran that same environment
requirements. txt today I will get a
different set of
packages this is fixed we have
containers
right all every it Department in the
world we have containers we fixed this
who here knows how to write a doer
file I'm sorry for you sorry who enjoyed
the process of learning how to write a
do who would be totally fine if they
didn't have to know that there was a
thing called do fils yeah every ID
Department everywhere is like just just
write a do file
that's too high of lift and the other
thing is what we've seen in you know
when we consult with a lot of
organizations and industries and
everyone else
is most organizations their it
departments or their you know their it
syst Dev op groups they used to
something like Oracle you upgrade Oracle
once every 3 years you know maybe if
you're really aggressive maybe you do a
you apply a patch every 6 months or
security patch a month they're not used
to data scientist say hey something
released on Friday can I have it you
know they're like no no okay fill out a
change order you know let's say okay you
want to change or to fill out these are
the packages get it signed by your
manager get it signed by your manager
manager and the manager manager manager
will put it in the clue in the queue
it'll go through our cicd system our you
know verification scan our security scan
and in about 8 months it'll be on the
production Docker image that you can use
and but you like okay I need the next
four versions now that you know and so
containers aren't the solution
containers give you reproducibility they
don't give you
flexibility who's ever started analyzing
a new data set or a new thing and only
after starting your project you realize
which packages you
needed yeah that's the problem with this
idea in companies that you can
Define all the software you need at the
beginning of a project we did one a
couple years ago where we were looking
at analyzing traffic data like you know
how many people turn left this
intersection stuff like that and there's
a really good Panda extension that lets
you do route routes and stuff we didn't
know we needed that uh but we needed to
get it installed quickly and
deployed most organizations are not able
to transition this issue between I want
flexibility and I want reproducibility
you you pick one or the
other there there are best practices
people have been around for a while you
learn what not to do you and and this
isn't all of them but these are the core
three I would say always use an
environment specification never write
pip install or cond install on the
command line never if you see a
colleague doing it slap them have them
write the requirements file that lists
all the packages they want they've done
that great not enough I told
you we we had this problem we were we
were doing a project for a company
around um recognizing brand images in
videos like you you see a video you see
the chase logo you want to say oh the
chase Lego logo is in this video um so
we found a good model that was built
about 8 months before the project and
they published a requirement of
txt it took us 2 weeks to get a working
environment because in those those 8
months so many of the packages they
depended on changed even though they
pinned some packages subdeep of of those
packages change so after you have an
environment specification you install
your environment and you create what's
called a lock file a lock file is the
exact list of every single package that
was installed because you have that
requirements.txt
including the hash and the you know
architecture and all that kind of
stuff second thing you you have an
environment you suddenly realize oh I'm
using pandas but all my data is in paret
so I need to install Arrow or I need to
install you know um P
Arrow do not type pip install P do not
type cont install p uh do not if you
need the next version of um pandas don't
say Pand P upgrade pandas no go back put
it in your environment
specification make a new environment
that is the safest way to have
environments that can be recreated okay
there are more if you do some of these
things you can have reasonable
reproducibility but doing this
consistently and remembering do it all
the time it's a lot of extra steps now
where are you going to put the lock
clouds are you going to store them
somewhere are you going to put them you
know how are you going to manage all of
this that's what we've been building
over the last couple
years it's a tool we call conosur and
we've taken some of the best practices
that exist for the cond
ecosystem um we're talking about making
it also work with pit but we'll see um
and
we're going from you tell us what you
want
want we will make sure we follow all the
best practices under the hood and give
you an environment that's reproducible
that you can transfer other people all
that kind of
stuff I'm going to go into a live demo
in a second but before that I'll just
show you the UI part of it the UI tries
to force you into a best practice it it
it uh you specifically have to you know
give it an environment name duh
um put out your
specification and then it lists what's
installed as dependencies it lists where
it's coming from and it automatically
creates a lock file a Docker image a tar
a tar GC that you can unpack somewhere
else you know so you're divorcing your
specification from the artifact the
artifact is an environment you might
want to run it locally you might want to
run it in the cloud you might want to
ship it to someone else's machine we
want those to be two separate issues um
we originally built this for the cloud
for uh Jupiter Hub and other Cloud
platforms where you have multiple people
but recently we also got it working for
a la and so that's what this talk is and
I'm going to go into live demo now
hopefully you'll go back to this XKCD
which is a lot older we're like oh
Python's amazing we can fly you know so
anyway I'm going to switch to live demo
which I probably should have use
different mic since now I'm going to
hold the mic and do this um so first I'm
going to go so this is a
um this is a cloud hosted version uh
because this has some extra features
that don't make sense in the desktop but
in the cloud hosted version you see I
have my personal space
here and these are environments that I
own I can edit them I can change them I
can do whatever you know I can basically
say you know add a new environment I'll
walk through this in a second um and
then we have down here other envir so I
gave a talk at pon earlier this year we
we did a tutorial and we have this Pyon
environment Pyon name space or group and
in this Nam space me and my colleague
pavitra have edit rights everyone else
who has access to python 2023 group only
has read writes so they can't change
anything here um they can just use the
environment and so this is some of the
more how how you can use cor store in a
corporate setting to have role based
access to environments and editing
environments and all that kind of fun
stuff I'm going to switch to a local
version so this is a local version
running on my computer and if you see
I've got a couple of
environments so let's actually create a
new environment let's just say
plus um let's see high data
NYC okay now I need some
help what do we want to
install python yeah okay that's good
python we can do python actually let's
put a version constraint on that um I'm
going to switch the Amo on actually
uh okay so let's do which version of
python 114 114 okay let's do 114 oh
actually let's make it equals okay okay
you know what I like polers I went to
polers talk earlier I think they're cool
okay so I got polers and thers good okay
so now I'm just actually you know what
let's actually explicitly say we want
this to come from CL
Forge you know we don't want to use the
default Str we want it to come from CL
Forge now here in the background it's
making uh environment. F same thing it's
just a nice UI on top of it but when I
hit
create this is kicking off a few things
it's kicking off a service that is going
to build the environment create a bunch
of artifacts create a lock file and and
I'm going to go back to here to one of
my created environments if we look at
let me go here let me look at something
I built recently I built this I was
playing with J SE earlier today so here
if you look I now have a Docker image I
have a lock file I have a log file I
have a tar uh one of the new features
that we have funding for that should
come out in the next couple of months is
also say build for all platforms right
now this is building the cloud versions
building for Linux and my local versions
building for OSX we're going to have a
check box saying I want you to try and
build an equival an environment for Mac
OSX and you know Windows um okay that's
great nice I get some environments now
here's the other thing have you ever
tried to install something and you had
an error and then someone asked you hey
what was the error I'm like I don't
remember there like stuff frenched I
can't find it now okay so I try to break
environments and so here I have fully
versioned environments so uh I can go
back to this one let me go back back to
this one and here I did something that I
know will break I said Panda's greater
than two and nump less than 1.2 I know
that's going to break and that that was
just for this but now I have a log from
that install so I can show it to someone
say hey this
broke
um but also you know I have all my
active versions actually let me go to
this
one so here this is my active version I
have psychic learn Port vision and torch
this this this one oh no no this is not
the one I was going to do I was going to
do this one okay so I've got torch
Vision High torch and pandas but now I
can go back to this one where I don't
have pandas and I can click edit and I
can say change environment version which
one I want to go to I want to go to this
one and change it and now this is my
active
environment so I can go back to previous
versions of my environment and there's
no resolve this is the exact environment
that you 6 months ago or 3 months ago
whatever so now you have the ability to
roll forward and
back perfectly without having to try and
reinstall from a old yo file that may
not
work
then um
and and you know let's see anything else
I was going to talk about um some of the
other things we're hoping to do uh which
we this is more the line is in the cloud
environment it kind of makes a lot of
sense that you have the um the different
groups and stuff like that but you can
also see we now have the base for saying
something like publish my environment or
get get my environments from my
colleagues or having that kind of
feature where you can upload or download
pieces let me there anything else I
show I think that's about it on the the
live demo um I will
say the desktop version I showed so
we've been using this in production with
multiple companies in the cloud in kind
of a data science platform jupa Hub type
setting for like 2 3 years now but the
desktop version and Mac um Mac
compatibility and windows compatibility
is basically bleeding edge uh it just
got merged a few days ago um and so
right now you can use this on your
desktop but it's not really production
ready yet it it works but you know
please use it and we should have a
release right now you have to pull from
Main we should have a release and an
installer in the next week or two um but
I think my mission here you know I've
been dealing with packaging and
environments for
years it shouldn't be something we have
to worry about we should be able to
install stuff we should be able to share
stuff we shouldn't have to deal with um
well it whats my
and so that's the goal that we're
pushing with this this project is now
part of the cond incubator thing so it's
something we built and then we've
submitted it and so it's it's on its way
becoming official part an official part
of Honda um through the incubator
program and you know if you want to use
it and give feedback great if you want
to help us develop it great we'd love
all that um I think with that I will
take
questions so this is creating cond
environments so the only thing the other
person
needs is Anaconda installed on their
computer no you don't even need anaconda
don't don't even need yeah you can well
you can use uh so there's a tool that
actually this gets into the weed
um there is a the simplest way is
there's a tool called micro Mamba and if
you point micr Mamba to one of these
lock files it'll just take the lock file
to recreate the environment on their
machine um or you could give them a link
to the do file you know um or if you
have an you could use an so there there
there's like multiple options once you
have that lock file um and then what do
I have to give them off of my laptop so
that they can reproduce it on their
laptop so ideally if you wanted I mean
okay so there's a couple of layers there
because are they also on the same are
they are you Linux and their windows or
are you Linux and Linux windows and
windows so so there's a couple of pieces
like that that are still sort of like
how do we manage that but ideally um if
if I if I show you
here
this lock file that's not yeah this lock
file is a Json file that exactly
specifies every package and it's hash
and where it came from and so with that
lock file and there's various tool cond
lock has a tool Mamba Min Mamba has a
tool so there are several tools that can
go from this lock file to a environment
you could also if they are on the same
platform as you if they're on like um if
they're on Linux you could hit this
download archive button and that's a zip
file that you can use cond to unpack on
and then cond to unpack in that zip file
will give you an environment and so and
theoretically we could also push a
single RV image or a cloud Ami because
it again this is a plugin architecture
we have specification we have lock file
we have artifacts we have art we have
plugins for Docker and a t easy file but
you could build your like if you wanted
to build a container for HBC system you
could build your own plugin to generate
that
artifact other
questions I feel like one of the things
that I often run into like you know at
this point when I'm building something
and I I'm creating the environment you
know I I follow the basic process to
some degree and I know what's there but
I'm also often working with old code
bases or somebody else who you know just
getting started with python like who
knows what they did on local machine and
it's like there doesn't seem to be an
easy way to sort of like figure out
automatically what you need from the
code no that's very very very difficult
right that's problem so you still just
have to go manually through look at all
the import statements and there are
tools which will help you find all the
import statements and pull them out but
that doesn't give you enough because it
says import pandas which version of
pandas was it
P you so and there are some things okay
we've done this for a couple of Bs
because they have a doer image that was
created by
people 5 to 8 years ago who were no
longer at the bank and no one knows
where those binaries came from and we're
kind of inspecting them and saying I
think that's number by one point you
know I think like you know
so forensics on that is really hard so
it's better to do it up front and
there's a talk one of my colleagues gave
at the packaging pond in Germany
and he his talk kind of goes over some
of the same things but from a different
aspect he said usually by the time
you're talking about reproducibility
it's already too late because you've not
thought of it early on when you should
have been thinking of and so this is
trying
to okay one of the big reasons we build
a UI on this because behind this there's
a rest API and there's like a server and
all this kind stuff the reason we built
the UI is you know as you said if you've
been in the community long enough you
know some of the things not to do and
some of the things to do it's very
difficult to take that experience and
push it to everyone and one of the
reasons we're building the UI is to
avoid having to do that and one very
explicit decision we made like some some
of the other uis we've seen um anacon
Navigator and there's another one called
Gator and stuff um it mixes what you've
requested with what's actually being
installed like if you if you even if you
look at your environments and you do a
pip freeze or if you do a cond list or a
pip list or whatever what do you get you
get every single package that installed
which you don't even know what happen
one is lip C++ D something standard
whatever that's why we very explicitly
this is what you ask for this is what
you got you didn't ask for forr but
guess what sci-fi uses for and pandas
uses
sci-fi and and so we're trying to make
it very explicit you don't need to know
about best practices but we will do it
behind the scenes so that's kind of the
approach because really if we want our
organization to you know use best
practices are you going to go to every
single data scientist or engineer and
like keep hammering on them on the head
with all these things I don't think you
should need to is is is what we what I'm
going for at
least
so I think you mentioned that cond lock
is the main locking mechanism for so
their their documentation
might oh and by the way you can use Pip
with this as well yeah of course um so
their documentation might answer this
for me but just because I'm curious the
most common situation I have in my team
is you have one person who writes a
library of super interesting things for
their nichal part of commercial sales of
health insurance or something and then
somebody else is like I love just
so they write their they put it up on
GitHub you can do pip install https you
get you get their package library and
stuff like that is this able to handle
locking things where half of my
dependencies are coming from internal
GitHub and other half are coming
from Yes uh okay so we're still debating
how to do this because so in in
this we we're trying to work out if we
we should expose that in the
currently if you click on if you click
on switch to yam editor here you can
basically say
PP
and you can put get plus and you can
kind of do your thing we're trying to
work out whether we want to expose this
to everyone because right now it's like
if you're comfortable writing the ammo
you can use that because it's sort of an
advanced case we're trying to work out
one of the big issues when you mix cond
and pip uh you can mix cond and pip if
you follow a few rules if you use cond
to install so digression the big
difference between con and pip is
because the PIP was built by the web
python Community condo was built by the
numerical Scientific Python Community
very I'm I'm glossing over lots of stuff
here
um python most core machine learning
numerical python libraries are a python
library on top of C C++ forr rust code
pip does not know how to handle C++ rust
libraries and dependencies in a
non-conflicting way uh and there's
there's multiple reasons for that cond
handles those very well so if you have
two different libraries that both need
zib uh a C library called zip both those
libraries can run it without conflicting
pip one of the packages can clob the
other one so the safest way to do things
is install all your core packages which
are numerical pie torch and nump and
pandas with cond and then pure python
packages you can install with Pip in the
same environment no problems if you
install pie torch with cond and in the
PIP section you in that same environment
you install tensor flow you're likely
going going to destroy everything
because libraries will get overwritten
and you know we've seen this chaos a lot
of times we are still trying we we have
we have Folks at quanite who are on the
cond steering committee part of Pipi and
stuff and we're trying to work out some
ways to automatically make cond and pit
work better together but that's in the
future a little bit and so part of what
cond store is trying to do is today
pragmatically what can we do with the
ecosystem as is and then hopefully over
time how do we fix the other
issues just is just for clarification I
I don't use but you saying I can install
umy within a environment yeah yeah
that's what this does basically this is
the yamama file basically you can put
all your cond cond packages up here and
you can put pit and you can put your pit
packages down here and it'll install and
and so the other thing pipon do is it
can't install python but um in in cond
you can actually install different
versions of python if python you know
you can actually go back to python 27 if
you want don't recommend it but you can
all right
so okay so if I install more
specifically if I install the pendency P
within a environment it'll be a part of
the same dependency
graph not
exactly um let me see if I can
actually
uh I think some of these inv
environments yeah right now
unfortunately all the
llms
um so if you look at this this looks
this is what you can see install like so
a lot of the llm companies everyone
who's doing in Chachi or something they
only have Pip they have horrible pip
installers that are very easy to break
your entire system um but uh if you look
at this environment I think if I click
edit you'll
see oh no this one doesn't have any p
okay one of these has a bunch of pip
stuff I don't remember which
one okay yeah um I can execute python
yes so here here you basically see I've
got a bunch of stuff coming from K like
DB and stuff and then these things Auto
GPT q and stuff are only available in
pit so a you have toage that yeah so the
thing
is this will work until Until It Breaks
horrible you know and
and you know but but at least now it
fails reproducibly you have error
messages you have a log and when you fix
it you can roll back and forth between
the broken and you know and the other
thing when we use this in the cloud
setting like so this environment of this
J llm one of my colleagues Dylan we said
hey go work out how to install how to
install llama and a few other things he
worked it out you know he got it working
and now everyone in qu can use it
because it's you know we we just pick
this environment when we want to run
that stuff so part of this is especially
in the cloud environments in Jupiter Hub
if one person works out how to build the
environment now every you can share it
with everyone else in the organization
without having to pass a file
file am I looking at two dependency
graphs here sorry for the diagnostic
question you are you you are looking at
a dep we're looking at a quer dependency
graph here and then we're looking at a
pip thing now the danger is if one of
these cond dependencies installed a core
C++
Library pip doesn't know cond and pip
can overwrite it and break it horribly
if they're name the same though pip will
see that install yes if they name the
same pip will see that it's installed
and not do it but for some there there
are a couple of package like uh some of
them are fixed like in the past in
condur as called SK learn and in PIP it
was called psychic learn and so it pip
wouldn't recognize it was in you know so
the this is that that's a whole let's
get some bear and talk for four hours on
perform in the pyone ecosystem but in
practice I mean I do this all the time
and I just try to install with it and
like it's not there and then I go find
in fif and then it just works yeah so it
just works time it just works so it it
it just works when you're an individual
um because you know half the time most
of the Python packages are just pure
python so it works fine we're a
consulting company who this is the
difference between anecdotes and
statistics I bet we're a consulting
company who works with lots of
organizations and once you're at the
scale of I have lots of people trying to
do stuff it breaks all the time and and
so any one person usually like they they
find something oh it works or like you
know one of the hardest things is
getting tens flow and py torch working
together in the same environment I would
actually advise if you're unless you're
planning to mix both of them you have a
t like that's why I named this one here
if you look here if you look here I
named this machine learning pie torch
because installing tensorflow and pipe
torch together is very hard and the
number of times I have used both of them
in the same workflow is basically zero
and so just have a pip environment and a
test flow environment environments are
cheap use
them oh yeah uh this seems to be pretty
informed by like npm and a lot of the
design decisions made there like it's
funny to see the JavaScript it's it's
actually not npm one of our developers
at quanite loves NYX and he's trying to
make all of this work like NYX with the
lock files and stuff like that but well
the lock files have been around for a
while um and it's so it's difficult to
say what came from where npm has a
another set of problems where it stalls
multiple versions of the same package
yeah well that's why they're trying to
do Dino now and I mean that's one thing
after the next but the one thing uh that
mpm done pretty well that I start to see
pip do is like vulnerability management
using like uh pip audit is there any
chance that you like want to add
vulnerability managements the guy to
help people better understand that so so
I mean we've talked about this again if
anyone has funding we would love to
accept it because we have so the thing
is we have every environment now has a
unique hash and we know exactly what's
in every environment all we need to do
is hit the rest API of a list of CV
vulnerabilities and now we can give you
a report for hey these are environments
you're running in your organization and
these what the vulnerabilities are you
know that would be easy with a little
bit of work well easy from the and more
importantly I think the challenge for
you specifically is making that stuff
really human legible because some people
some people will see extremely benign
some it departments will see extremely
benign security warnings and do absurd
things
reaction so the
cont okay every environment has a unique
P you mean every environment that's
created will be Supply to Unique cach or
do you are you saying that in terms of
the content itself so um we're storing a
lot of this metadata in a backend
database and so when this uh so actually
one of the things which so so how this
you know this whole active environment
previous version of environments are
working is every environment has a
unique ID and then on your desktop we're
switching
what you know data science points to you
know with Sim links you know so you can
kind of use the latest one or what move
back but we have a full rest API here so
theoretically and we've experimented
with this in your jupyter notebook if
you store the hash uh the ID of the
environment or in a script if you put
hashbang bin cond store you know ID
number we've experimented with it
automatically downloading that
environment unpacking and running your
script in that environment so once you
have a source of Truth for your
environments and you can ship them
around there's a lot of things you can
do
um so
okay in other words if I upload this
environment um
and regardless of metadata you know I
can name it I I don't care about
metadata if I upload this environment to
your system twice will I receive the
same unique Iden okay so that gets into
a different question is there a service
around this no currently this is
software you install and use you can
install it for your organization you can
install it personally what I would love
to get to is you know I come from a
science background we get to Mint Eis
dois for documents right if we have a
PDF or like a report we have a DOI I
would love to build a service that mints
a environment identifier that is unique
and anyone can look up and you basically
send your code to someone and say hey
here's the environment identifier and
you can pull that would be what I'd love
to build right now this isn't there yet
this is the this is a technology a
service like that could be built on uh
but it doesn't exist as a service we we
use this internally we use it we have a
cloud data science platform called
navari that's an open source T Hub
distribution we use it in that we use it
at several of our clients for each of
them they now have a unique source for
their environments but that they don't
have a way to share that with someone in
another organization we could we've
talked about um if you look at the
Shared environments that section uh if
you look at that shared environment
section um here this bottom section
theoretically that could be environments
would exist on someone else's server and
you click download or upload or
something so again if you think about
this systematically there's a lot of
stuff you could do with it so again
anyone wants to fund us I'm happy to
take money to build this more so and you
know we
also last plug we are a consulting
company if you are really annoyed about
how your organization or your group
deals with environments we're here to
help both on the pocketing side and also
Building Systems like this so any other
questions can you also help get packages
added to cond through Fe stocks like
there's AA Forge yeah cond I mean kind
for yeah we do that for multiple
companies we're actually doing some for
the Niah where we're getting the biology
packages uh or and converting our
packages uh to publish on cond Forge and
so we actually have we're I used to be
on the steering committee for cond Forge
but I uh for cond and then I Ste down
but we have steering committee members
on both cond Forge and cond and um we
have several developers in P ecosystem
and in the PIP ecosystem so um yeah
that's one of Consulting Services we
offer it's just hey here's a list of P
just get them on and we also teach
people how to do that like you know if
if you don't want us to actually do a
little little training on how to do it
someone still has to approve the pr on
the Hond side which can take
some amount of not when they work at
your
company hey h can you this Pi no we see
usually we see if it's going through the
regular process efficiently but if it
gets stuck we have multiple people who
are account for core maintainers so they
can kind of push it and say hey let's
get this one uh through the thing
so hey thank you everyone and
I'll